[Music]
Heidi and Spencer Pratt are definitely
planning on attending Justin Bieber and
Haley Baldwin's nuptials eetzi caught up
with the reality stars along with their
son Gunnar on the red carpet during the
Daily Mail TV summer party where they
couldn't help but gush over Haley's
recent engagement and her father Stephen
Baldwin the three met while on set of
I'm a celebrity get me out of here in
2009 the more the sinned the longer the
duck I was just telling my weightlifting
coach Sifu today I was like god I wish I
had stayed in more contact with the man
who baptized me in a Costa Rican river
on a reality show because I'll be going
to the JB Haley freaking wedding but you
know I've been DMing him like hey hey
and if you heard back from oh not yet
but he's Rio Latvia no I added him I
didn't DM yeah I was gonna wait so it
was a date for the wedding we're
definitely planning on heading to that
wedding she was like 12 Spencer also
opened up about some of his a-list
celebrity encounters and how they've
come about organically I don't know if
I'm just on their best days with so far
Ben Affleck Taylor Swift and Justin
Bieber we're the most amazing humans
I've ever come in contact
they were so freaking nice this was
faith it's just God like knowing I'm
trying to be next to a listers Taylor
was set up we were invited but JB no our
door open and behind me all sudden is
Justin Bieber and then I go to my
breakfast burritos and opening the door
he's been having am i he's very he's a
big guy - he's Batman long toilet we're
gonna go hiking with Lindsey shook is
sorry Jen
[Music]